[Música]
cientos de personas marchan en el pueblo
natal de la joven fallecida maxa mini
quien perdió la vida hace 40 días bajo
custodia policial en Irán hay denuncias
de una fuerte represión en estas
movilizaciones en rechazo a su muerte
balance positivo después del encuentro
entre el presidente de Francia Emmanuel
macron y el canciller Alemán Hola en
París ambas partes se destacaron la
cercanías de sus relaciones en un cara a
cara en el que la crisis energética y la
defensa fueron los principales asuntos a
abordar tenemos informe desde la capital
francesa
a cuatro días de la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales en Brasil
continuamos con nuestro cubrimiento
especial en Francia 24 Hoy les hablamos
de la controversia en torno al
mandatario Yair bolsonaro y su aumento
en el gasto social en plena campaña
tenemos informe
momento de actualizar las noticias aquí
en la pantalla de France 24 Yo soy Juan
pupiales y gracias por estar con
nosotros
damos inicio a esta emisión informativa
en Irán en donde cientos de personas se
reunieron en la tumba de la joven maxam
para conmemorar los 40 días de su muerte
tras ser detenida por la policía de la
moral la ong hangout denuncia que hay
heridos después de que las fuerzas de
seguridad dispararán contra
manifestantes en saques ciudad natal día
minín la televisión Estatal reporte de
enfrentamientos y en esa localidad
mientras que las protestas continúan en
las calles de diferentes regiones del
país conectamos en este momento con
nuestra corresponsal entera en Catalina
Gómez Ángel Catalina va terminando la
jornada allá en Irán qué balance podemos
hacer acerca de esta jornada de
manifestaciones y además como usted nos
ha venido contando es una jornada que
también tiene una carga simbólica para
los chiítas
es un era un día muy esperado era el día
número 40 después de la muerte de Max
samini y esto traía incluso Memorias de
la Revolución en 1979 cuando el 40
aniversario de las personas que iban
asomías han sido muertas volvían e
incitaban a nuevas protestas como la que
hemos visto hoy en no solamente
recordemos que no solamente miles y
miles de personas fueron al cementerio
acompañar a la familia en este día de
luto Allí se cantaron algunos eslóganes
bastante fuertes no solamente muerte al
dictador que hemos oído durante esta
semana sino también hablaban que el
kurdistán era el cementerio del fascismo
pero también Vimos
una
el comercio estuvo cerrado en la mayoría
de ciudades de esta de esta región
también vimos otros pequeños comercios
cerrados en Teherán y en otras ciudades
de Irán donde hay protestas incluso a
esta hora se oyen por ejemplo desde el
centro desde eran se oyen como hay
misiones de la la policía se oye en
pitos en la calle y a esta hora también
se reportan algunos disturbios no
solamente en el kurdistán como hablaba
sino enteran y otra parte Catalina el
margen del caso de Marc agencia Estatal
de noticias interna reporta que hay al
menos 15 muertos después de que hombres
armados se saltaron un importante lugar
Santo Chita en la ciudad de chiras al
sur del país que sabemos sobre ese
ataque
Es realmente muy confusa la información
que nos llega desde chirás estamos
hablando de una ciudad mucho más liberal
en el sur de Irán donde hay un gran
mausoleo donde sucedió esta esta
asesinato durante la tarde a las 5:45 de
la tarde se habla algunas versiones
hablan de al menos 15 muertos otros
hablan de 40 heridos hablan de tres
personas responsables que las agencias
locales quieren relacionar con lo que
ellos llaman grupos táctiles A qué se
refieren grupos sunitas islámicos como
podría ser en su caso el estado islámico
o al qaeda ellos lo que dicen es que hay
por lo menos dos personas que ya están
detenidas se dice que otra habría
logrado escapar pero viendo en este
momento
perdemos la conexión con nuestra
corresponsal entera en Catalina comesa
Gómez ángel avanzamos con más noticias
cambiamos de tema este miércoles el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron
recibió en el Palacio del Eliseo de
París al canciller alemán Olaf scholls
este encuentro entre los líderes de las
dos principales potencias de la Unión
Europea se produjo en medio de una
atención por temas energéticos y de
defensa Pero al final ambas partes se
entregaron un balance positivo los
detalles de este cara a cara los tiene
desde la capital legal a nuestro
periodista Luis Miguel Cabrera quien
previamente nos envió el siguiente
informe
un encuentro muy constructivo el
almuerzo de trabajo de este lunes entre
Emmanuel macon y olas scholls tanto
Berlín como París destacaron la
cordialidad del intercambio y la solidez
de las relaciones bilaterales ambos
líderes evocaron un espíritu de trabajo
muy estrecho a mediano y largo plazos
uno de los acuerdos fue de hecho
establecer grupos de trabajo en las
áreas de energía defensa e Innovación En
ese sentido choles tuiteó que Francia y
Alemania permanecen muy cerca y están
abordando los desafíos juntos la
reuniones se extendió por tres horas más
de lo previsto pero fue un tiempo bien
aprovechado para dejar claras las
posiciones e intereses de ambos países
en los temas que corroen aún la relación
bilateral no obstante sin conferencia de
prensa ni declaración conjunta Aún es
difícil conocer en detalle Cuánto se
avanzó para resolver las discordias en
los referente a los precios del gas que
macron quiere limitar y shorts dejar en
manos del Mercado o sobre las
inversiones de Berlín en el área militar
que no incluyen participación alguna de
Francia al menos en el escudo
antimisiles antiaéreos que pretende
construir Alemania con tecnología
estadounidense e israelí en resumen
menos tensión en las relaciones pero
problemas de fondo aún por resolver
seguimos en Europa en Reino Unido el
nuevo Primer Ministro es una fue al
parlamento para responder en su primera
sesión de control desde su Asunción Este
martes allí protagonizó ya una polémica
al volver a nombrar a suela breberón
como ministra del interior además el
gobierno decidió aplazar hasta el 17 de
noviembre el anuncio sobre su plan
fiscal el informe lo tiene Andrés
granadillo
primero encuentro en el parlamento
richizona que respondió a la ronda de
preguntas de la oposición donde fue
criticado por volver a nombrar a la
ministra del interior suela braillerman
considerada el ala derecha de los
Stories y quien tiene una fuerte línea
sobre la inmigración la ministra
renunció hace una semana Entonces por
incumplir las normas del gobierno
podemos ver lo que ha pasado aquí el
Primer Ministro es tan débil que ha
hecho un trato sucio comerciando con la
seguridad nacional porque tenía miedo de
perder otra elección de Liderazgo hay un
autor y en la cima pero como siempre con
ellos el partido primero el país después
salió al paso a sus detractores
ha preguntado por la ministra del
interior la ministra del interior
cometió un error de apreciación pero lo
reconoció planteó el asunto y aceptó su
error y por eso estoy encantado de darle
la bienvenida de nuevo a un gabinete
Unido que aporta experiencia y
estabilidad al corazón del gobierno
el Primer Ministro también respondió por
los planes para superar la crisis
económica en la que está asumido Reino
Unido
señor presidente he sido sincero
Tendremos que tomar decisiones difíciles
para restaurar la estabilidad económica
y la confianza y mi honorable amigo el
ministro lo expondrá en una declaración
de otoño dentro de una semana
el esperado anunció que pretende
recuperar las finanzas públicas fue
pospuesto del 31 de octubre al 17 de
noviembre este aplazamiento la primera
decisión política de sunac desde que
tomó el relevo detrás pondrá más presión
sobre el Banco Central de Inglaterra que
en su reunión del 3 de noviembre deberá
decidir si sube o no las tasas de
interés para controlar una inflación
desenfrenada sin conocer aún los planes
del gobierno
en noticias sobre la guerra de neucrán y
ahí dos personas murieron una de ellas
una mujer embarazada y otras tres
resultaron heridas tras un bombardeo
Ruso en una gasolinera en la ciudad de
nipro en el sureste del país el alcalde
Boris filatov informó en su cuenta de
Telegram que la mujer embarazada perdió
la vida en el interior de un vehículo
Mientras que el otro fallecido era el
operador de una estación de lavado de
automóviles entre tanto Rusia volvió a
señalar a Ucrania ahora ante China de
sus presuntos planes de un ataque con
una bomba sucia un dispositivo que
combina elementos en radioactivos el
secretario general de la otan lo
desestimó
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos porque a
menos de dos semanas ya de que los
estadounidenses acudan para las
elecciones de medio término se empiezan
a conocer los primeros resultados del
voto anticipado por eso conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal en Washington DC
Cristóbal Vázquez Cristóbal que arroja
este balance temprano
lo hace la universidad de la Florida que
tiene un centro de estudio electoral y
dice que hasta el momento son cerca de
9,5 millones de estadounidenses que han
votado de forma anticipada casi siete
millones ha mandado su voto por correo y
casi aproximadamente dos millones y
medio de estadounidenses se ha acercado
a las urnas de forma anticipada a votar
en estas elecciones de medio término que
recordemos pues no solamente están en
juego 35 sillas al senado 435 sillas a
la cámara de representantes sino también
36 gobernaciones y 34 alcaldías en todo
el país además de cargos públicos
locales que también están en juego se
espera entonces a partir de esta
votación que la participación sea
récord de hecho en Estados como Georgia
ya se registra un millón de votos más en
comparación a las elecciones de medio
término en el 2018 se espera que los
afroamericanos las mujeres y las
personas los adultos mayores las
personas que tengan más de 50 años sean
los que más acudan a las urnas en estas
elecciones Y es que Obviamente el clima
político en Estados Unidos está bastante
polarizado hay temas por ejemplo como la
seguridad temas como la inflación y la
economía y temas como la migración que
los republicanos Pues están aprovechando
para impulsar este discurso que lleve a
que más simpatizante republicanos salgan
a votar por el lado de los demócratas se
están aferrando bastante al discurso de
El aborto para impulsar a muchas mujeres
a que salgan a votar y precisamente los
afroamericanos y las mujeres están
batiendo récords en cuanto a
participación en estas elecciones de
medio término
listo algo así es gracias por este
reporte desde Washington DC seguimos en
el continente americano recta final para
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones en
Brasil a cuatro días del balotaje del
gobierno de Jair bolsonaro toma medidas
para dotar de asistencia social a medio
millón más de personas en condición de
pobreza una decisión que violaría las
reglas electorales pero que no ha sido
impugnada por el izquierdista Lula da
Silva quien las adoptó también en el
pasado entre tanto La Apuesta de Jair
evolucionaron por la reelección en
Brasil ha encontrado inesperados aliados
simpatizantes de la izquierda
conquistados precisamente por las ayudas
sociales
afuera del centro de bienestar de este
suburbio obrero de Río familias enteras
hacen cola algunos incluso han dormido
aquí con la esperanza de recibir por fin
El auxilio Brasil el beneficio social
creado bajo el gobierno de bolsonaro que
acaba de ser aumentado en casi 40
dólares justo antes de las elecciones
desempleados y residenciados en la
vecina Fabela de marea yoiani Elí y
Johnny Siempre han votado por la
izquierda Pero esta vez el presidente y
sus valores profamilia han ganado su
voto
tengo un hijo de 4 años y estoy
embarazada no tengo trabajo así que esta
ayuda es muy valiosa para mí para
pagarme alquiler mis compras mis
medicamentos también recibimos un cupón
para ayudar a comprar gasolina
[Música]
quién te ayuda te bendice y para mí ya
ir bolsonaro es una bendición soy
cristiana y votaré por él porque ha
demostrado que apoya a las familias
aunque no esté de acuerdo con todo lo
que dice está del lado de la familia
Jair bolsonaro no solo Ha logrado ganar
nuevos votantes en los barrios pobres
que solían ser bastión de la izquierda
sino que también ha conquistado muchos
pueblos pequeños y rurales
en el estado de ríos San joset valleduo
prietos la localidad que más voto a
favor del presidente y candidato en la
primera vuelta su apoyo ha crecido En
comparación con 2018 la mayoría de los
residentes son cristianos evangélicos
como él pero no es la única razón gran
defensor de los terratenientes
bolsionaron su poco placer a estos
pequeños productores en medio de la
escasez trayendo fertilizantes desde
Rusia
desde nuestro punto de vista Esperamos
que obtenga más fertilizantes y
productos del exterior para ayudarnos a
los productores pero también para ayudar
a la economía de Brasil como lo hizo al
bajar el precio de la gasolina que se
disparó y nos afectó mucho
claro parecen de Dios
Parece ser más sincero Aunque coincido
en que se equivocó durante la pandemia
se retrasó en la compra de vacunas y
mucha gente murió por eso creo que será
una mejor opción que Lula para mí
Estos son votantes conservadores
moderados con una cosa en común el miedo
a que regresen al poder Lula y la
izquierda a quienes consideran corruptos
terminamos con información que enluta al
mundo del arte a los 102 años murió el
pintor francés
reconocido por su trabajo en torno al
color negro la noticia la dio a conocer
el presidente del Museo del artista en
la ciudad de joden profundizó en
destacar el color negro y su carácter
activo a lo largo de 75 años sus obras
llegaron a hacer unas de las más
cotizadas en el mundo del arte el autor
afirmaba que utilizar el color negro
junto a uno oscuro lo iluminaba
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
pero ustedes quédense aquí en la
pantalla de frases 24 visiten también
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]